hey everybody its Jesse and the problem
that we had yesterday we were working on
trying to send data to Reich which is a
project management system through the
Reich API from our react forum we
couldn't get it to work well now it
works thanks to Kevin who had a pull
request and I didn't check the times
exactly but I'm pretty sure that Kevin
was able to get it working in less than
three hours which i think is pretty
amazing so just to put it in context as
maybe it will help you see why I think
this is so amazing so when I was trying
to get this to work months ago using on
the client-side in the browser using
jQuery I probably worked on it for at
least a week maybe more before I got it
to work and I had already been using
rike sosa miliar with it a little bit
not necessarily using their API but
Kevin was able from the time I think
from the time I ended the stream
yesterday to the time of the pull
request was about three hours so he was
actually able to set up an account with
write a free account get the API key
learn enough about the API to actually
get it working all within a few hours so
anyway just amazing so if anybody out
there is looking to hire a good
developer definitely recommend Kevin
because that was just super impressive
I mean he's been really helpful
throughout the entire project but I was
I was very impressed with with that
especially since like I said I had so
much trouble with it when I first
started working with it so I've only
added on just a bit to what he had had
done today was actually I had a meeting
like literally as soon as I got here I
didn't even get into my office I still
had my laptop in my backpack and
everything and I just went straight to
my meeting and so I haven't and then
after that I was never really added a
lot of time a straight stretch of time
to work on anything so I haven't really
gotten that much done
I was I was able to do a little bit so
I'll show you we're starting to get a
lot in the server.js file which I think
I had said that that that was going to
happen so it's starting starting to get
a little bit hard to find everything but
let me let me see okay here's this stuff
where we're doing some things with rike
and I don't know what is going on and
sorry sorry for that just to my train of
thought it's just derailed but it smells
like I don't know like gasoline or
exhaust from heavy machinery in my
office right now like really strongly so
there's construction going on in the
parking lot they're repaving everything
so there's a lot of equipment there so
maybe that's it but it's really weird
like my I'm on the interior of the
building so it's not like I'm near a
window or anything so I don't know if I
if I pass out during this dream then
somebody called Franciscan University
and tell them to come get me out of my
office um Wow it's just really strong
I'm gonna keep going because I just
started this dream but we'll see
hopefully it's not hopefully it goes
away I'm gonna
turn a fan on just the lowest setting so
hopefully that's not too noisy for you
all I also do have the Instagram stream
going so I had some people stopped in
there if you're watching on Instagram
and you'd like to see the code on my
screen that we're working on please
check it out on the free code camp
YouTube channel okay so here's what
we're working with here see I mean
obviously you can see what's been done
you can also check it out on github
I've already merged in Kevin's pool
request if you check out the pull
request it was pull requests 31 yeah it
was 31 so he provides an explanation of
what the issue was and how he fixed that
let's see Patrick also helped out as
well so he had commented on the pool
request and so it was great work there's
also an issue going on right now that
Sebastian had had raised yesterday
during the livestream and then he
actually opened up a detailed issue on
the github repo about the tests failing
so there's a pool request open right now
pull request 33 that is being worked on
so Sebastian and Kevin and Patrick are
all trying to figure out what the issue
is so I haven't pulled it in yet because
it's not if we get it to a point where I
think the problem is solved then I'll
pull it in but for now just know if you
were getting some errors like some
timeout errors on the tests that it's we
might have a fix and when I say we I
mean they because they're really doing a
great job on it and I've I've been
working a little bit on some other stuff
on here
okay so let me let me just go through
this quickly basically this is pretty
much what fix things so if you remember
we were we were trying to put this data
in you know same day that pretty much
this these things I added and I'll
explain this in a second so with the
exception of these two lines all of this
is from Kevin so some things that he did
have to change he had to add this
content type header and then also had to
encode these key value pairs so if you
want to see more of an explanation of
this like I said check out the pull
request but that's where we're at now so
that's pretty much all that changed and
as far as what I did so basically
without these two lines this makes a new
folder and Reich but I needed to make a
new project which I don't even know if I
said that yet but Reich has folders
projects and tasks so the highest level
in the hierarchy is the the project and
then within the project you can have
multiple folders and multiple tasks and
things so I'm actually I'm not sure how
it all works so we use it as a
department as a whole we write to
coordinate things like a high level for
my projects I use Trello it seems like
right can do a lot more than Trello can
but I don't need that more so it's
easier for me to just do things really
simply in Trello since it's usually just
me and you all working on the project so
anyway to make a folder I actually
needed to add I'm sorry to make a
project instead of a folder all you need
to do is add project and then assign it
an owner ID and let me I'm not going to
show you the the actual variables but
I'm going to change them just a bit
and then show you what because I had to
do a little bit of a strange thing to
get it to work so let me bring this over
so that y'all can see okay so this is
from my dot n file it's not my entire
file obviously but these are what I
added here this share ID and owner ID so
you can see how I had to put it put it
in I actually needed to make this an
array in quotes otherwise it kept saying
that it was invalid and for this one I
had to make an object with owner IDs and
then an array with the ID that's the
only way would accept it I actually
attempted to put all this stuff in here
and then just you know had the idea
within it didn't work so probably tried
I don't know maybe five different
combinations of ways to do this and this
was what ended up working so if you are
working with the right API and you're
having issues with this this is how you
have to do it
I do remember having similar issues when
I tried to get this to work with with
Ajax on the client side and so I just
for that I think I had to do like some
escaping of quotes and things like that
but basically this is the format that
Reich is looking for so not sure if any
of you are actually using light right
you need to do this but okay so I just
got some messages on my Instagram feed
that they actually evacuated my building
but it looks like
I see some people on the hall I think
we're good so evidently there was gas in
the building they did evacuate nobody
seems in a hurry I'm just gonna keep
going
I'm sure if it's that big of a deal
somebody will knock on my door and maybe
we'll see actually I'm gonna check the
live chat now because I have and I
completely forgot to check the live chat
let's see okay I still had a lot chat
open from yesterday so I was looking at
the wrong one for a second let me close
that okay so hey everybody
oh cool Gavin says hey checking in from
Jamaica awesome
and I also says he said day five in the
series
alright cool you you've remembered you
said you're gonna start at the beginning
of the series so you've caught up with a
5 to 5 days already so that's great
shyam says total newbie when it comes to
react that's cool that's cool I'm still
I think I'm still somewhat of the new
bit myself this is a good place I'll try
to explain as much as I can
thanks I am says that he'll call if I do
pass out so thanks
okay so Gavin says his tests are also
failing locally okay so it's I mean I'm
not happy to hear that other people are
having problems but it's good to know
that at least like it can be replicated
which is good because then we could
probably narrow it down
it looks like some people were coming
back into the building so maybe it'll be
alright actually hold on one second I'm
gonna ask what's going on I turn on the
fan and I told the people watching me if
I passed out the conference okay so the
evacuation is not mandatory I think um
I'm good I'm gonna stay and I'm gonna
keep streaming and they said the the I
guess it's from gasoline oh I'm not sure
what's going on but they said it should
dissipate soon so I'm slightly
lightheaded right now but also I've been
feeling a little weird all day like
tired and stuff so if you if you see me
on the Instagram feed I have like my
eyes definitely look like I'm really
tired so anyway yeah I was up kind of
late last night working on the react
course that I'm taking that Udacity
course you can actually do a lot of it
on your phone which is cool so I was
putting the kids to sleep and on my
phone doing it and then signed up just
staying up and doing it which is cool I
guess I'm learning Redux which is
awesome but I had dreams about coding
all night and I actually had a coding
nightmare so I'll get I'll get to the
coding it I'll tell the story this will
be the last thing before I get actually
get to the coding so I know I know some
people are a little bit
annoyed by the amount of talking I do so
I I'll be done in a minute
uh-huh but anyway I had a coding
nightmare that that last site we worked
on the cata catechol institute site that
I looked at the site and somehow they
had managed to change it all and do the
layout with tables and they had like
this weird inset border thing that just
looked like it was straight out of like
the 90s and totally changed the colors
everything the images were like all
stretched and like not the right
dimensions and I was like I was freaking
out so actually my wife like was trying
to get me to wake up anyways she like
touched me I just like jumped up I'm
just like wow that was it was terrible
so I guess normal people have nightmares
about like I don't know like scary
things like what but I have nightmares
about people changing my layout to using
HTML tables so anyway it looks like cool
there's some discussion going on in the
live chat about those errors with the
test so that's awesome so thanks for
like I said um I'll pull it in I mean uh
if I I haven't been that involved with
it one because I had never gotten any
errors so if I can't replicate the issue
I probably not really gonna be able to
contribute that much to fixing it so
also it seems like Kevin and Patrick and
Sebastian are getting to the bottom of
it and seems like you all are close so
hey not bad I have a few people in the
Instagram stream that's cool they're
given some given some love and Instagram
so thank you alright so
let's do this let me tell you what we're
gonna try to do and then then we'll do
it so right now where we are is that
when I hit the submit button this does
make a full project in Reich and I would
show you what's going on but I don't
want to show you all the stuff that's
that my department is working on just
there's probably nothing secret in there
but just in case somebody would get
upset about me showing it I don't want
to do it but basically it is working I
was able to get a project made what
happens when the project gets made is
that we get data back and we get a bunch
of data back you can actually see what
what comes back here so I can I can
atleast show you an example of what we
get back so this is the response that we
get when we create a new folder or
project in this case we've we were
actually creating a project but they
send back pretty much the same thing
either way and what we really need is
this ID so this is the ID of the project
if we have this ID then we can attach
files to that project so unfortunately
you can't attach the files at the same
time that you send the initial data so
like all our form data we actually can
send initially but we have to wait until
we get this ID back so we're gonna get
the ID back we're gonna get this value
and then we're gonna use that to attach
our file so we're gonna check out
attachments
we want to create attachments yes
okay so we'll be using this folder so
there's not a separate URL for projects
there I guess considered the same loves
folders like I said I'm not exactly sure
what what the difference is really and
Reich but I just know that the people
that use Reich a lot said that they
would much rather have them be projects
and not folders so I made them project
so we're going to do
basically this obviously this is not in
the format that we need to put it in
right this is curl but this is what
we're gonna do
let's see mm-hmm usually they give they
say like what everything is that you
need to put in the in the call no
they're not doing at the Sun okay well
basically we'll need the same thing so
we need our access token like we're like
we're already the language yeah no big
deal we're gonna give a file name
Content ID oh here we go
and then here's our attachment content
so I've already done this with with Ajax
so I'm going to I'm gonna show you all
how I did it with Ajax cuz that'll
probably be way easier to read than this
curl I don't know about you but like
that's not really a format for me if
you're using postman you can actually
copy and paste this and then convert it
to whatever format you like so that's I
mean you could do that if you want but
since I've already done that before and
converted it to be able to use it with
Ajax I'll just copy that over
so I do need to remove my API key from
this so just a second and I will I will
do that
okay
okay so this with Ajax accomplished what
we needed so the only thing okay so
here's what that project ID goes so in
our our URL we just need to add to the
to the end actually not to the end
because then we still have this
attachments here so be folders then the
project ID slash attachments okay so we
need to okay in our headers are bearer
obviously after bear this is where our
API key goes okay so I've removed that
but there needs to be an API key there
and then we just need to add these
headers and then our data is going to be
so I mean obviously this is a variable
from what I'm doing on the current site
so let me see
I just I'm looking at the code on the
other screen and like I said there's API
keys in it so I can't show you as well
but I'll try to bring over what I can
okay I don't I don't think I'm gonna be
able to do this in exactly the same way
as I did so let me just show you how it
was getting that all right so wow this
pace over so so weird let me change this
to there we go
at least we get some syntax highlighting
so what I was doing to get the files
since this was all client-side
I direct Lee had access to the Dom
elements so I was getting the upload the
actual upload input and then grabbing
the files from that to make file lists
so not really going to be able to do
that
so I can't exactly do what I did before
but you get the idea of what we're what
we're gonna try to do so the first
things first is we need to be able to
get this ID from the response okay so
let's see we already have an example of
the response which let me go back to
that
create folder there we go
okay so this is what we need to grab
inside data we need to grab ID so let's
try to get that and I've forgotten my
timer so let's see that as well all
right so right now we are getting
actually let me see
I'm gonna check I'm gonna check the live
check because it looks like there's
something in here that's definitely
relevant
okay Kevin says it makes more sense in
this case to put the get the attachment
from the server yeah well I mean we're
already you know we already have it in
the server we're saving it so I agree
all right so let me does I think that I
I will be able to show you the response
let me check it really quick to make
sure that my API key is not in there
okay yeah oh I will be able to bring
this over then
oops
accidentally it's smaller instead of
bigger so then make this bigger so y'all
can see so this is currently what we're
getting back and that it would be
so we're we logging this early down here
okay so here's where we do the Reich
folder you're passing in the what ends
up being the name of the folder project
okay so we're longing it here
nice let me I think this is what this is
right that's why we're we're logging not
this but this part right our status that
we're getting back
okay Sebastian says oh so you might want
to limit the file types that people can
upload yes I'm definitely going to do
that so I'm gonna keep saying that for
for myself so that I don't forget and
thank you for reminding me so yeah
before any of this goes live definitely
need to make sure we do some some things
to limit what can be uploaded or you
know whatever at the very least we're
gonna limit what can be uploaded
I'd like to whatever reasonable steps
should be taken when you handle file
uploads with node I would like to take
those steps so I may need to maybe maybe
I'll just do some research
I'm sure there's there's some stuff out
there about it
but let's see for now
so I just want to say just can I grab it
like that I don't know if that's gonna
work let's see let's see what we get no
not gonna be able to do it like that
is that actually we're kidding
that's weird how did that crash
oh sorry I was still like I talked about
yesterday I still have not done anything
to to fix the Corsair so that I was
getting and now what did I do
oh that's the one right check let me
close that cuz we're definitely not
gonna use that I'm not gonna use this
are they
let me just use
what I'm gonna do I can't decided I was
just gonna use Firefox
in Harris the
it's not telling me what what the air is
Oh
all right what did I do
okay it should have started
yeah she just started it let me
okay
Oh syntaxerror what did I do
oh it's because I tried to console and I
forgot to put a plus
all that because I forget to put a plus
sign oh well template literals have
spoiled me Oh
remember to put the plus sign in
okay
now let's see what happens
okay so that that in fact is exactly
what we want
all right let me check
[Music]
I'm gonna check the live Chad
okay thanks Kevin I should have checked
the live chat about six minutes ago to
avoid in some of this okay so the status
status right now is coming in as a
string that's that's why
so basically we're right here see it
says text so it just wasn't thinking so
I need to change it
it's a JSON and
now let's see what we're getting
so yeah let's try this data let's see
what we get
there we go here's what we need all
right great
so look I can't believe it took what
like ten minutes to get to that point
about most of that was spent trying to
figure out why how I messed up the
server but anyway this is what we needed
all right so we have the ID that we need
I can get rid of this trying to think if
there's value in keeping the rest of the
status I really have no need of anything
else in that status right now so I guess
I'm okay with just pulling out this this
ID okay there were a few other things
about the server in the live chat so let
me scan through that quickly
okay Patrick says you can set the
accepts property input on the front end
so I can in the browser client side but
you should also check on the back end to
prevent people from getting around it
yeah for sure
so actually if you've never worked with
file upload inputs before that's a
really good point so basically you can
set on the input itself what you want it
to be able to accept but people can get
around that so I guess like really
easily and I don't know maybe you've
done this before like you can just
inspect something in dev tools and then
change it change the HTML and then it
will change the way that that field
functions so a good example of this is
like a password field
so if you have a password and password
field let's say like you you don't
remember what the password was you can
just go into dev tools take out password
as the type of input and then all of a
sudden you'll be able to see the string
instead of those little dots so a
similar thing could happen so basically
doing client-side checking of what the
files are and restricting the files is
not enough because you can get around it
easily so you want to do something on
the server side as well so ideally you
do both because you do it on the client
side so that immediately the user gets
feedback that hey you can't you can't
upload that otherwise they try to upload
it and depending on how you set it up
potentially they might not even have any
idea that there that file type is wrong
so you do it on the client side
basically I mean it's pretty much for
user experience because people can get
around it if they really want to and
then on the server side that's where
you're checking things and that's more
for security the user never sees that
they don't even have to know about it
but that's where you really want to make
sure that you're not gonna like execute
a file
it's gonna mess up your server today
that's my lesson on security today
okay so Patrick is giving me some advice
here about how I can make the server
work
all right so let me share this so
what
how's my permission denied indicating me
oh well whatever
[Music]
okay so let's Oh I'll worry about the
the server later I guess not really big
deal like right now it's knowing what I
needed to do for what we're working on
right now
okay so just try to remember where we
were all right so we have our ID next up
is send the files based on that ID so we
need to basically we're gonna add
another another one of these and so I'm
like I'm gonna copy this because a lot
of its going to be the same
so we're going to take in actually read
it we're not taking two things right
yeah so we need let me think
we need the ID obviously but then we
also need the files
and let me see how are we getting this
file objects
okay
all right we'll just give it to file
[Music]
so you don't need to we don't need so in
our body basically we don't need any of
this stuff we need just the just the
files and okay post is fine this is the
same content type it's gonna be how do
we have to loop through this I
I mean shake it just occurred to me that
it I may only be able to send one file
at a time so I'll have to loop through
the files and keep sending the request
so I mean that only changed slightly how
we do it yeah that actually won't be a
huge deal so with I guess then within
actually within here might not be a bad
place I mean right now all we're doing
is just console logging whatever the
files are so that will still console.log
just to make sure that it's working but
within here we could probably call like
add attachments and we're gonna need
actually we are we're gonna need that ID
I had to be careful the order here so
we're not actually so within the on end
we're making that first call to Reich
and then we're getting the data back and
then after that is when we want to send
the file otherwise we're not gonna have
the right ID so this is not the place to
do it then
here yeah not the place to do it but I
still need
I wonder
all right I have a few ideas I don't
think the first one will work let me
tell you well a few my ideas are and
then I'll give everyone a minute if let
me know if you think they'll work and
Hut so the first idea is I just do this
form on file function and I put that
down here so after we get the status
back just run that down here I'm
thinking hey if that works that's great
I'm just not sure if it'll work if I put
it in here but we'll see that's probably
the simplest thing the alternative would
be inside of this right here where it
currently is I save the files yeah so
I'll save the files to a variable here
and then just use that down here and
pass that along with the ID I mean
obviously like with within a loop like
I'm I'm gonna have to call that multiple
times
yeah okay so those are my two ideas I
guess I'll give you a minute to respond
to that but the first one would be so
easy to test I'm just gonna do that so
I'm gonna copy and paste this and
[Music]
I'm just gonna put two their side don't
mix it up alright so basically all I'm
gonna see oh I'm looking to see is do I
get anything there let's see will you
need to upload a few things let's upload
three files so we should have that
shouldn't be called three times
and that doesn't know so from right here
so we had it it ran the first time and
it did not run the second time okay so
for whatever reason that does not run in
here so I mean we could try to make that
work or move on to the second one my
time is up for the Pomodoro session so I
am going to take five minutes and go
back to the live chat
all right so for now I'm looking away at
the bottom just to see what would you
all have to say about what I was just
doing and then if I have time I'll
scroll up and see if there's any
questions
okay Kevin says loop inside the then of
the right night folder okay she's saying
loop inside
this then correct which is what we're
gonna try to do
okay kevin says it didn't work because
we're we would be listening for files
after the request was already parsed so
since we're we were trying to do this
and listen for files inside this on end
right it's it's already and it's already
been parsed so enough nothing's
happening at this point so of course
it's not gonna pick up on that so this
then is definitely not gonna work so let
me just remove that and move to move on
to plan B
all right Rohan's here hey everyone
how's it going
Rohan asks what did I miss basically we
are we're able to go from our server Jay
s file and then on Form submit make a
new project in Reich and then we get
back the ID of that project and we can
take the ID now and we're going to
attempt to use that ID to send files and
attach them one by one to that that
particular project
okay I'm scanning really quickly to see
if there any questions that I missed
trick ISS asks can you tell me how to
group content in HTML with div and span
properly so not sure if you're still
watching because that was asked quite a
while ago but if you are I mean I would
say properly I don't know that there's a
proper way to do it it depends on what
framework you're using and what you're
trying to accomplish in terms of what
divs and spans you use generally most of
what you do is going to be in divs you
know your spans are more like shorter
blocks of content like within like if
you if you had a paragraph for instance
and one line of that paragraph or even a
few words you want to add some special
styling to that would be a good place to
use a span but the if you had larger
chunks of content then you might want to
use a div generally that's how how
they're used if you're using a framework
like an by framework I mean like
bootstrap foundation materialise they're
gonna have set out how they manage the
layout of the page and they're usually
with a div structure so a lot of how you
do your your divs is gonna be based on
what that framework is already laid out
so if you're doing it from scratch and
you're doing everything I mean you can
lay out your dues however you'd like but
like I said in general if it's in line
like with within you know paragraph
spans work well you know a small piece
of content otherwise divs are usually
used you know for major layout things if
you're trying to make like some cards on
the page those would be divs hopefully I
answer the question I said not sure here
you know watching still but maybe it'll
be helpful to someone but anymore I
always use some sort of CSS framework so
the structure of the divs is basically
already decided
hi Gavin I just saw the comment he said
it sounds weird hearing my voice at
normal speed because you've been
catching up it always sounds weird when
I hear my own voice on these things
probably it doesn't matter what speed it
is it's always weird
okay so my timers up I did get about
halfway through checking the questions
so all of them go back up we'll do
another Pomodoro session here and then
I'll answer some questions so hey Mark's
here hey how's it going you you still
still looked in the new job is it going
well
let me know I haven't I haven't heard
about it in a while alright so it looks
like cool Kevin has put some some code
in the live chat that will most likely
do what we're trying to try to do here
let's see Kevin always has good code so
I'm confident that assuming that I can
paste this in the right spot it will
work
so let me just paste this it's really
hard to like read out code so let me
paste this in here so y'all can see what
I'm saying
so basically okay so pretty much what we
were basically this is the club code to
make like plan B work so we have a files
where files and we're going to save the
files to this so then we can access it
later on even within this form on end
and yeah and then we leave this leave
this where it is right because it won't
work otherwise
all right so it's I'll put it up here at
some point I'll probably remove this
because I won't need the console.log the
files but I it would be good for
troubleshooting to leave it in at least
for now okay
probably actually don't need the name in
there but I was even in for now okay so
same thing that's going on here except
instead of console logging we are adding
the files to this array so files push
file right
okay then and since we'll have all the
files in this array when we get down to
here we can oh yeah
okay yeah down to here so we get down to
here we will have gotten the ID back
right so we can get the ID from here and
then we can call our function that's
going to attach the file but we will
want to loop over that
all right yes okay
files use coded files right can we do
map on this I know it was confused a
couple days ago about trying to use a
map on things that you shouldn't use map
on but it's an array right so we can use
map so file add attachments and it's
gonna be ID
all right so now up here
all right here we go
yeah okay yeah that's the right order
for now let me get rid of this and I
just want to
so I should be able to get the file name
out of that so let's make sure that this
works
ideas not defined
oh I'm sure you've already seen the
mistake that I made but what I I just
use ID and instead of actually getting
the ID here so what I need is this
there we go
now let's give it a shot whoops file was
not defined
oh because I was saying files and we're
not sending files were only sending one
file at a time so better to name it file
anyway okay there we go okay awesome so
it's working in the sense that it is
calling it the correct number of times
for each file and we're getting data on
a different file each time so in this
case we just console.log the name but we
have you know the whole object there it
is correctly giving us the ID as well
great so that's what we need to work
with now we just need to use the right
format to send this I forgot to start
that again
awesome so I commented out this bit here
also we'll probably I mean we're not
gonna want to run this like if there's
no if there are no files so we'll
probably want to check first to see if
there's file but for now I'm not worried
about that I just want to get it to work
and then I can check
okay so I had started to put in what I
needed here and then I I don't know what
got me sidetracked but I dropped down
and started doing some things down below
there so now we need to okay so we're
sending we're not gonna send files
anymore we just want the one file
so in the background my music today is
some really like mellow jazz it's the
coffee table jazz station on Spotify so
you have to let me know do I seem like
more relaxed and mellow am i coating
better than normal or not usually I
listen to way more upbeat music like
electronic music and stuff so I'm kind
of interested to see what would affect
different types of music have on my
coding not really very scientific can't
really keep all the factors the same
from you know each time I code but
you'll see
okay so Kevin said it's it's fine to not
check for their files because if there
are no files the loop would just run
zero times yeah that makes sense this
cool all right well we have actually a
really low viewer count today not sure
what's going on maybe maybe I am really
really boring today because I'm I'm too
mellow because I'm listening to the Jess
anyway I'm not really sure what if it
causes people to view or not view some
days there's a lot of people in some
days there's not and I'm doing the same
thing pretty much every day alright so
we need here on the other side this is
what we need so let's add in headers
content
yeah
oops
and we can get filed me
content-type oh now I remember why I
went down cuz when I looked at this and
these two I realized oh we're only
sending one file at a time and that's
when I started thinking about how we can
get one file at a time okay
oops
I think that's what it is we'll find out
awesome and okay so instead of data we
have body okay and file will work all
right so this looks oh we need the URL
to be different so I need the ID in
there so I'm gonna I'm not gonna use an
environment variable
I'm going to use a template literal and
with the ID and then attachments
great
all right that should be enough actually
I don't know I'm not really sure if I
need these we'll try it without it but I
guess we'll see we'll see how it goes
okay so let's see
okay so when we hit submit this time it
should create a project in Reich with
the title of tests it's not gonna have
any data in there because I'm not we're
not actually putting any data in there
right now
it might have actually we will it'll
just say folder description as the the
body of you know the project will get
the ID back and then it will add
probably we'll just do the same three
image files will get added to that and I
will verify that on my other screen
where I have reich open so I'll be able
oh man
well yeah we actually just made a ton of
test folders so I bet our project
manager is wondering what's going on
so anyway whoa let me delete quickly all
the tests folders we have now so I don't
have to search through them to find
which one is the one we want to look at
there's no batch delete option and
that's unfortunate because I have a lot
of testing
so I guess Reich recently came out with
a desktop app which is kind of cool but
also not not really great because I had
thought that one of the first desktop
apps that I would try to make once I
finally learned how to make desktop apps
with react would be a Reich desktop
client for my my department but they
already beat me to it so I guess it's
cool either way we have it I just
thought it would be cool to do but
anyway let's give this a try now
so I've deleted out all the other tests
that we made whoa crash what'd I do
oops I put at least I remember just to
check this
I D is not defined where
Oh
why is ID not defined we're getting an
ID
okay that's why
all right let's give it a shot
all right so I've seen the project has
been created and awesome let me see
did the file go through Oh No okay so
the project was created the file the
correct file names came through but when
I try to click on them it says the file
appears to be invalid or broken sorry we
can't load it so I did something wrong
but so here's what we know is working
which the good news is we know that it
is actually getting the ID back and it's
sending in this case three requests so
it's sending a request for each file
that we've we've uploaded which is great
the correct file name is getting there
the only thing is the file itself is not
working which I didn't really check what
let's see so I'm sending
this
okay I'm not sure why that happened
let's take a look so we're getting the
file scroll down here okay so here's
your eating the files from on file okay
so the files here
all right let me let me check the live
chat to see what y'all think okay
Patrick says for each would be more
appropriate okay cool I'll change that
to four each
Rohan says I need upbeat slash EDM or
something similar for me to get to do
anything yeah this morning I don't know
what it was I was listening to some like
really upbeat electronic music and I
don't know I was just feeling weird and
was feeling like I don't know like a
little bit like I was getting a headache
and I couldn't focus and I thought like
I don't know like maybe I just need to
chill a little bit
so I so I did so I relaxed a little bit
I put my feet up on my desk and just
listen to some jazz for a bit and I
started feeling better so that's why I
went with it but like 90 probably 95% of
the time I do this in the upbeat music
Oh
okay Kevin I just saw your message about
the content-type is that's what what's
messing this up actually that makes
sense maybe the content-type is doing
that so what maybe this isn't where I
need to get let's see file type
now actually that it that is it it is
tight that's what I need
it's twice oh okay that that makes sense
good good either
okay cool I'm I'm actually really happy
about that because that that was
probably our a problem and otherwise I
was a little bit at a loss as to what
could the issue could be all right is
even another shot okay no errors let's
check it out
hmm actually I got the same problem as I
did the last time this do the order does
the order matter here I'm not sure if
the order matters but I guess when I did
it over here where did I have it at no I
had it here so it shouldn't matter
I think what's going on
I just want to see what we're actually
getting and we do this okay
that that seems like the right type
right
try content type application okay let's
try
okay so let's check out so in the
example reusing oops this is not it
in the example it's using this is the
content type so let's give that a shot
same thing same issue
okay so I actually downloaded the file
from Reich just to see what would happen
so yeah it won't be damn it she's a file
format preview doesn't recognize okay
see
okay right now I'm just kind of looking
over the code and seeing if I can see
something and think of something that
that we're missing here
I wonder if they're looking for
something like we had had done before so
actually no we didn't end up doing that
I'm sorry I was thinking about one of
the possible solutions to this and I
think what I was thinking I've ended up
not working anyway
well we we got pretty far without
hitting a really serious issue so it's
not bad I do want to see the times yeah
I want to give this working so this
stream may end up being a bit long but I
have an appointment at 5:00 p.m. which
is its Eastern time so I can definitely
go for Fri another hour so let's say
let's give this issue like a half hour
and that would leave a half hour for
questions probably won't need that long
but you never know maybe we'll need it
and I say that just because there's not
a whole lot of viewers right now so
let's let's try anyway so we got about a
half hour about another we'll do one
more Pomodoro session to work on this
problem we'll take our five minutes to
do a little some some questions and
catch up in the kinda live chat
I'm just right now I'm just going
through right now making sure I didn't
misspell anything
okay just checking to see like the files
that we are getting are being uploaded
and they work so something something's
happening and we really transfer the
files then
all right well yeah I figured that
Sophia
all right so now's a good time to take a
break usually when I get stuck like this
if I do take a little break it's usually
I'll get some idea at least something
new to try so I'm gonna go back to the
live chat I'm gonna scroll up to where I
left off at before and try to get to any
questions or see if I missed anything
and then in five minutes we'll go back
to this problem at this point honestly I
don't have any ideas for what to try
next so hopefully I think of something
now we got a few more viewers it was
actually we're down to sixteen viewers I
saw at one point which is crazy we're
never that low so I don't know what's
going on the only times we've been this
little before is once the YouTube
notifications weren't it just people
didn't get them a lot of people didn't
get them and then the other time I was
trying to stream during some big tech
conference and the tech conference was
live-streaming and I didn't realize it
so other than that we usually have more
people than this all right where'd I
leave love okay
alright see there's still a lot of
discussion about this
there's Aires
okay cool so it looks like Gavin was
able to get the test to pass so that's
that's cool good to hear that
okay Patrick and Rohan I see I see
everything you're saying about trying to
get the the localhost 3000 to work so oh
they said I'll try that out later on
today or maybe early tomorrow
haha now I said I see how many times you
all were trying to tell me that I had
content-type in there twice sorry I
didn't I didn't look over and see that
thanks for continuing to try to try to
remind me about that
okay Joseph said that that that actually
works so basically the way that we're
doing it up here worked for you and
postman so I wonder what's going on no
page John Hanson said finally I caved
and installed create react app so over
the last oh I don't I don't even know
how long John's been working with react
but trying to set up react and web pack
and everything from scratch so he
finally went with create react app which
if you're not familiar with that that
lets you kind of bootstrap react project
and get started without having to know
anything about web pack so alright cool
let me know how it goes then at least
you can get started and start doing
react stuff and not worrying about your
build
okay John John Hanson said that he got
his YouTube notification exactly on time
so maybe it's not the YouTube stuff who
knows what it is
oh wow okay so Patrick's and YouTube
notifications haven't been on time in a
month sometimes he gets notified the
next day wow that's crazy
kayvon I'm not I'm not sure how you how
to pronounce that exactly that what
syllable to put the emphasis on but I'm
gonna say
kayvon and then because we have a
Kevin's I'm gonna try to differentiate
that but is asking if I use Redux so I
did not use Redux for this project but
probably be using Redux in a future
project because I'm learning it right
now so I'm taking a course from Udacity
on redux
so I was working on it earlier today on
my lunch break
so Redux will be coming most likely as
soon as I get done with this course and
I get a project where it would make
sense to use redux okay so that was I've
gotten to the to the end of the live
chat and I've also gotten to the end of
that break so let's give it one more
Pomodoro cycle and give it a shot try to
get this to work and we'll see so
basically like everything is working
just how we want it I mean we obviously
we need to fine-tune things before this
would be ready to go you know in a live
situation but basically everything's
working except the files won't go
through properly it's in terms of like
it won't open we get the file name it
shows up as if it's a file but when you
click on it it says the file appears to
be invalid or broken so let's try I'd
like to try maybe this is try a
different file type so I have this xcf
file
and see if that works
mmm
and actually that's weird
that did not get through at all
I mean let me show you again let's
refresh show it one more time
that's odd it's actually it is creating
when I do that it's creating new
projects but it's trying to add those
three there we go finally for for some
reason when I try that the first two
times it was trying to add the same
three files again really weird all right
so let's see it looks like it did the
same thing for this as well I'm gonna
download it and open it up just just to
be sure
well there we go and it said it cannot
open the image all right
so definitely doesn't matter what type
it is
all right so I guess now it's time to do
a little bit of research then and maybe
I can try
I'm sure either either stackoverflow or
we're gonna go to NBN's documentation on
file files let's see
okay got some stuff
so that's a good sign let's see I'll
pull this over and
let's see this so nothing obviously with
Reiki API alright so I got a few up here
let's see what's going on
okay a lot of less ones for this let's
see doesn't seem to be fixed
all right let's try another one let's
see if that won't ever get fixed
okay so this is we are using SendGrid
and our files actually might not maybe
we can try I don't want to try it right
now but if we can't figure anything else
else out maybe we could try to send the
file as an attachment to our emails that
we're sending through SendGrid and see
if we can get it to work through there
maybe that I mean at least maybe we
could rule rule some things out maybe
but let's see what's the
all right that's not going to be helpful
all right I'm not sure okay so it was
false broken
okay not really anything there that's
useful
okay no answers for that one all right
let me check and the live chat here
looks like there's a few things
okay so Kevin I see your comments let's
try them out I'm going to try to do some
debugging
okay
all right let's see what we're getting
there
that's odd which should it be
[Music]
I guess that's it's close enough I was
thrown off by the type right but I guess
that's what is supposed to be
okay so kevin says formidable files
don't appear to be noted buffers which
note fetch handles well so maybe reading
the file directly from the path with FS
read file to get an actual buffer okay
so let's see I'm gonna need some help so
see where so where am I gonna do
where am I gonna put FS da tree file
are we talking like where we somewhere
in here where we're grabbing the files
the project managers sent me a message
on slack and said dude I'm getting like
a test email every minute from you yes
this is happening
okay so let's try to put
okay so can I do something like this on
this this file before we send it over or
do I need to put it higher up
guys this we're talking this is we're
talking about here
okay not there
that's so Patrick had a good idea that I
could just set up a free bike account to
use for testing then I can show you all
what's going on and I won't spam
everyone else with this stuff that's a
great idea she was excited that when I
told her I'm working on the new version
of the Resource Center so don't think
it's that it's that big of a deal but it
would be cool to be able to show you
what it looks like
okay let's see
I suppose you said path to an upload
directory file where
all right so I see Kevin and Patrick are
putting some code in the live chat for
me but all right so I'm a little bit
confused all let me paste this up here
so everyone can see I'll get rid of this
stuff
all right so kevin has posted this and
Patrick this
and I'll have to wait a minute there's a
look there's a delay on the video so
I'll have to wait a second to get a
response here so
so I could put this
okay John Hanson said I'm confused too
thanks for saying that Jonah it makes me
feel better I'm not the only one that's
that's confused yeah Kevin and Patrick
you guys are awesome and so I don't
you're just like both of you are so
knowledgeable and I think you're just
like steps ahead of me all the time so
it takes me a minute or two to catch up
and figure out where you all are at okay
so we it looks like we have a better way
than to do this so let me show you the
latest okay so if it's rifo
so this is going to go then we're in in
here
or do I need to put this inside here
instead of
okay patched it inside the files thought
map which should be files thought for
each okay yeah I never changed the
Fourier so each is it file of files or
file in files I can't remember which one
it is
we'll see see if it works
okay this in all right thanks Ron
[Music]
I don't know I don't smell the gas
anymore here but I'm definitely feeling
lightheaded
maybe I'm just used to it I can't even
smell it anywhere
oh okay cool Patrick says I can just do
files that or yeah where my follows up
for each and then
well
let's cool
all right so
now I'm going to put that in here and
then get rid of this portion of it and
this portion yeah okay
that's great okay so we have files for
each ferry foul
I think this is what you're trying to
tell me so I mean just check this out
okay so instead of the file we're
sending this buffer all right
okay so we need the file name header
which so okay so that's not I can't get
the name anymore from that so maybe I
should just pass in I mean I know I can
get it on the of ik so I guess I could
pass in a name and tight
oh this is a good sign look at that file
size I'm feeling good about this one
let's check it out I'm trying to find
which one is the the right one cuz
they're all just named test there we go
all right
it works yay let me see I can show you
I'll show you a little bit of it
basically I'll just zoom in and hide all
the stuff that I'm not sure whether or
not I should show just because it's
exciting that it finally works so here
we go check it out so anyway Liz sorry
I'm putting your name out on YouTube but
[Music]
there we go there's our files and
there's our our project tests folder
description here and our files
so just in time this just went off right
after we get it to work so that's
awesome I'm excited I'm happy let's just
really quick kind of go over what we did
that made it work and definitely thanks
to Patrick and Kevin for figuring this
one out because I was I had obviously
tried everything that I could think of
at the moment so let's go so basically
the the what we did different then was
instead of sending you know whatever
this file was that we were sending and
we used FS read file and
we were able to get the buffer and put
that in there so I'm not familiar with
with this FS rifo I'm not familiar
enough to explain in any more depth than
that why it worked but just hang if
you're trying to use a similar setup
which sometimes people are sometimes I
get messages from people that say like
that they've cloned my repo and then
they're modifying and using it for their
project so if you're trying to do
something similar this is the fix
probably want to read up more on exactly
what's going on here
so I'm lazy I'm not gonna attempt to
explain it because I don't I don't know
enough to feel comfortable explaining
how this works I've never used it but
that was the solution and awesome yes
I'm celebrating going on there in the in
the live chat so yeah really awesome
it's it's great whenever we can get
things working figure it out so alright
so I'm gonna go now and do some question
and an answer here in a minute so if
you're just here for the code that
portion is done otherwise you're going
to stick around for question answers put
your questions and the live chat now and
I'll try to answer them you could also
ask me questions on any social media
channels and I will try to get back to
you as soon as I can I will say this I
have I'm a little bit behind on the
YouTube comments on getting to them all
so I've just been obviously really busy
between work and then some side project
work that I have for clients and the
Udacity course and then my wife and four
kids it's it's pretty busy so I do I try
to get to the comments I've seen some of
them and just not really had time to
give you a good answer so I I'm not
ignoring you so if you're waiting on me
to reply
comment I'll try to get to it whenever I
can so anyway before I get to the
questions just quick recap of where we
are and where we need to go so from this
point we can get data from our form that
data can then get emailed it can get
sent to a project management system
along with the file uploads our file
uploads are also getting saved to our
uploads folder so what we need to do
then is actually send the data that a
user uploads through the form okay so
from all those text inputs and check
boxes okay so we need to send that
format it in a way that's somewhat
decent so that it shows up in a readable
way in our project management system in
our and in our emails and then we need
to put some sort of security measures in
place to limit what gets uploaded what
type of files get uploaded probably want
to limit the size of the uploads as well
I I suppose could get crazy if you know
we get a really huge people trying to
upload a lot of really huge files so
probably want to do a limit on the
number of files that can be uploaded at
any one time and also the size that any
one file can be let me think and I guess
that's it for the forum the only other
thing we had talked about doing that I'm
still not sure about is having some sort
of database to store this data or
possibly sending the at least the data
from the text fields and checkboxes to a
Google sheet just to have a backup
somewhere so still not sure about those
may or may not happen we'll see and then
other than that we do have one other
forum that's going to be a very simple
form to deal with no file uploads just a
few text fields and we just have some UI
stuff you know some basic things
probably the only difficult I won't even
say difficult the the most difficult
thing
that will have to deal with after this
is our images because we're gonna want
you'll see I'll show you in an upcoming
stream but our images are using isotope
so I don't if you ever worked with
isotope before but a JavaScript library
that's called isotope and I can't
remember if it depends on jQuery or not
so we'll see but we'll try to do
something similar with react and see
what we can get all right so now I'm
gonna go to the live chat and let's see
yang Jian Xiao says I'm new here it
seems like I'm at the end hi yeah you
are you are at the end so yeah sorry
about that but you will yeah as I'm
Berto says you'll be able to see the
recording so you thanks for for joining
in though and thanks for for saying hi
in the live chat hopefully you can make
a live stream in the future at some
point
okay so I have
okay so okay Danny see Danny says thanks
for answering my questions on Instagram
awesome
yeah you're welcome no problem so yeah
as I say I'm on lots of different social
media things and I'm I'm happy to answer
whatever you know questions and things
that you that you have let's see she she
Jun says hi hey how's it going thanks
for for joining in so I'm gonna scroll
up a bit I did get through most of the
live shot already so I won't have to
scroll up too much but I want to just
double check make sure I didn't miss any
questions
okay I'm Blair tail has some some
helpful tip here it says one small
editor thing that I use a lot in Visual
Studio that works in Adam - just
different keystroke if you want to move
blocks of code up or down select the
lines and push control arrow keys
instead of cut paste okay cool I see I'm
gonna try that
so I don't know if I don't know if you
gave me the keystrokes to do it in
Visual Studio or an atom but I'm gonna
try it so ctrl arrow keys alright that
didn't work this rectum I know
okay so different yeah different in atom
so I'll have to see what it is an atom
but that yeah that actually will be
helpful to me so thank you for that
now billion says you sound like Remi
Malik that's cool I've never had anybody
say that before but I'll take it I'll
take it I like I like him Umberto's says
I love mr. robot yeah so Remi Malick is
the the guy the actor that plays the
lead character on the show mr. robot so
actually I watch season 1 and then a few
episodes into season 2 so yeah it was it
was pretty cool it was really
interesting just just I don't know to
hear about all like the different like
hacker stuff and how they do things
it was pretty interesting although I
haven't seen anybody that's watched
after like season basically from the end
of season 1 on is it still good like is
it should I try to watch the second
season then I mean season 1 was pretty
good
okay so maybe it's different on a Mac to
do let's see let me try it again yeah
and then I tried command
I tried control yeah while controls
doing crazy stuff on my other screens
let's try option no not option no yeah
not really sure it's probably some
combination command command control oh
cool
Joseph awesome thank you so Joseph came
through with the correct so if you want
to do this which actually looks really
cool now that I'm doing it on a Mac on
Adam on a Mac you use command control
and then your up and down arrow keys
that's really cool I like that and for a
single line you don't need to select
anything yeah let's try that oh nice
check that out don't even a select so
that was that came from Kevin thanks
Kevin
that's really cool alright rohan says
season two of mr. robot is good alright
awesome so it is just season two season
three have they had a season three yet
all right
well I've gotten to the end of the live
chat this has been over to our streams
so I'd say now is the decent place to to
stop okay cool it's I guess season 3 mr.
robots coming out in October
alright cool good to know off to check
it out and see the last time I checked
on Amazon Prime video they only had
season 1 but maybe though maybe they'll
have season tution since season 3 is
coming up but I think that's that's
about it for today
I'm actually pretty exhausted I don't
know if it's all the gas streams that
I've breathed in today if you're
confused by that watch the beginning so
or just in general being tired or you
know exhausted from all the code but it
was pretty cool we definitely
accomplished what we wanted to
accomplish today thanks to to your help
and so tomorrow I'm not exactly sure
we'll be doing tomorrow whether we'll
try to polish this a little bit more or
move on to something different
we'll see but thank you so much for
watching and for for all the help and
the live chat I really appreciate that I
will be back tomorrow and probably same
time I haven't checked my schedule yet
but probably at 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
and we'll work on this a little bit more
so until then have a great day